بين قائد وجندي في فريقه فالقائد
يقف في مقدمة الصفوف. والجنود
ملحمة بطولية سطرت بدماء الشهداء
واسست لمرحلة جديدة في الصراع
جنين ما زالت حاضرة في والبطولة
والاقدام. حالها حال الضفة
يضعون رؤوسهم على اكفهم. ولذلك
لا تنكسر عزيمة المقاومين مهما
دبابير. وحاولت اجتياحه قبل
عملية السور الواقي اكثر من مرة.
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي وتحدي
المقاومة لاقوى جيش في المنطقة.
القائد نصر جرار الذي اصيب في
ذلك الاجتياح. وهناك حيث لا فرق
قدموا فكل ذلك من اجل الوطن. بعد
عشرين عاما على معركة مخيم جنين.
وفي كل مرة كان جيش الاحتلال يجد
اهل المخيم له بالمرصاد يتصدون
كل البوابات المؤدية اليه باب
حطا وهنا وقعت اكثر من مائة
والنضال. واستشهد خلال المعركة
اثنى عشر قائدا قسامي من كتيبة
وفي ذلك الحين اطلقت قوات
الاحتلال على مخيم جنين مصطلح
والغاز المسيل للدموع والاعيرة
النارية ها هم يلحقون المصلين
المسجد الاقصى وتخرج المصلين منه
بعد اعتدائها عليهم بقنابل الصوت
لذلك اهمية كبيرة بما حملته من
رمزية للمقاومة والاستبسال
عقدين من معركة جنين ها هي قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتحم
من ثلاثمائة فلسطيني. قوة
الابطال. بالعودة الى جنين على
مدار خمسة عشر يوما وقفت
المقاومة ضد محاولة اقتحام وكان
العلوية من الجسم لم يكتفي
المحتلون بذلك بل اعتقلوا اكثر
اليه. ما هذه القسوة. وقدرت قيمة
الدمار الذي لحق بالممتلكات
التي كانت في الغالب تخرج منه.
هناك حيث يصنع الابطال وهناك حيث
المصلين في المسجد الاقصى معظم
الاصابات تركزت في المناطق
ورد في تقرير الامم المتحدة. كان
مخيم جنين هدفا مهما وعقبة
حقيقية لفرض الامن الذي يحلم به
الاحتلال بوقف العمليات الفدائية
يزال معتقلا حتى الان. ويقضي
حكما بالسجن المؤبد. وشردت حوالي
ويعتدون عليهم بالضرب ويخرجون
معظمهم من باحات الاقصى ويغلقون
المخيم. المقاومة الشرسة التي
لاقتها قوات الاحتلال المقتحمة
ذلك من ثبات المقاومين. يا له من
صمود اسطوري لم يجعل اي انجاز
تعجز جحافل المعتدي. وهناك وضعت
فلسطين للمقاومة عنوان. ما اشبه
اليوم بالبارحة. في ابريل من
العام الفين واثنين وعشرين وبعد
الغربية المحتلة والنصر ينبت حيث
يضحي الابطال بارواحهم لاجل تراب
وطنهم. وشعب دعائمه رجال تتحطم
الدنيا ولا يتحطمون. ودائما هناك
والصمود توغلت الاليات العسكرية
وسط المنازل وهدمتها على رؤوس
الدبابات والبلدوزرات الضخمة في
هدم المنازل بهدف التقدم صوب قلب
الذريع في تحقيق هدفه الذي جاء
من اجله. وهو تدمير رح المقاومة
للمخيم حينها اسفرت عن مقتل تسعة
وعشرين جنديا وضابطا اسرائيليا
اربعمائة وخمسون اسرة. بعد ان
حرمها الاحتلال من مأوى تلجأ
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي. حينها
اجتاحت الة الدمار العسكرية
وتضرر نحو الف ومائتي منزل
واعتقال العشرات بينهم من لا
اجتياحها مسألة وقت. معركة
دامية. على الرغم من الفارق
اصحابها. وتدخلت طائرات الاحتلال
لدك المخيم الذي يسكنه ما يقارب
بحتمية اقتحام جنين نظرا لكونها
ثقل فدائي خلال الانتفاضة وان
اربعة عشر الف لاجئ سبعة واربعون
بالمائة منهم تقريبا اما دون
الاحتلال على تبديل وحداتها
المقاتلة ثلاث مرات دون ان ينال
حتى بعد ان اخرجهم من ارضهم بغير
حق قبل اكثر من خمسين عاما.
العامة والخاصة بحوالي سبعة
وعشرين مليون دولار امريكي. كما
لجنوده بكل شراسة وثبات. هناك
وخلال اجتياح المخيم. اسماء سطرت
بدمائها اروع الملاحم والتضحيات.
وكانوا قدوة في الدفاع عن الوطن
والوحدة في مواجهة المحتل
الاسرائيلي وخاصة انها كانت
وهناك اجبر صمود عناصر المقاومة
خلال الاجتياح قيادة جيش
المقاومين تسليم انفسهم والخروج
من المخيم. بل واجهوا اي محاولة
واثنتين وخمسين اصابة جراء
اعتداء قوات الاحتلال على
لدخول اليات الاحتلال بالمقاومة
العنيفة. وبعد فشل الاحتلال
الخامسة عشر او فوق الخامسة
والستين من العمر لاحقهم المحتل
يحسب للقوة الاسرائيلية المقتحمة
ليجبر الاحتلال على استعمال
الاقصى وعلي ريحان ابو جندل من
جهاز الامن الوطني والاجهزة
للمقاومة كانت هناك عشرات
المدرعات وكتيبة من جنود جيش
المهول في التسليح مقابل الاسلحة
الخفيفة والعبوات البدائية
فتح وحماس والجهاد واتفقوا على
تفعيل العمل المشترك لاعتقادهم
الامنية. وحسب بعض الروايات فانه
وقبل حصول المعركة اجتمع قادة
يضمهم جميعا. وخططوا لمعركة
الكرامة المعركة التي لم ينس احد
لحظة الانفجار في وجه جنود
الاحتلال. غرفة المقاومة
واستشهاد ثمانية وخمسين مواطنا
بين ثلاثة وعشرون مقاوما. وهدم
التابعة للاحتلال المخيم بشكل
شامل وواسع وذلك بعد رفض
واحد وتركوا الخلافات التي بينهم
جانبا فقط من اجل الوطن الذي
الى اليوم. ضمت الهيئة القيادية
المشتركة محمود طوالبة من الجهاد
لكنه لم ينل من تبات المقاومين
او يؤدي الى اي انجاز يحسب للقوة
العملية العسكرية التي اعلنها
رئيس وزراء الاحتلال انذاك ارئيل
الاسلامي وجمال ابو الهيجة من
حماس وجمال حويل من كتائب شهداء
الزمان الثالث من ابريل عام
الفين واثنين. المكان مخيم جنين
المشتركة. عندها توحدت جميع
القيادات الفلسطينية على قلب رجل
عبثا ادرك المحتل ان وراء كل حجر
داخل المخيم يقف مقاوم ينتظر
المروحية. والهدف صغير لا يتعدى
نصف كيلومتر مربع. صنع الاحتلال
في الضفة الغربية المحتلة في
فلسطين. كان حصار مخيم جنين ضمن
الاسرائيلية المقتحمة. عن معركة
مخيم جنين نتحد وللقصة بقية.
والفرعية لكنه فشل في تدمير رح
المقاومة والصمود اجتاح المخيم
الثقيلة الاسرائيلية. الالاف من
الجنود وكثير من الطائرات
طوقا عسكريا على جنين وعلى
سهولها وجبالها وطرقها الرئيسية
معركة جنين عشرون عاما مرت على
ابرز محطات الصمود الفلسطيني.
الذكرى العشرين لهذه المعركة
تعود الروح الانتصارية للمقاومة
الاقصى ضد الاحتلال. اختيار
المخيم مكانا للمعركة لم يكن
عملية عسكرية واسعة. عشرات
الدبابات والاليات والاسلحة
شارون واطلق عليها الصورة الواقي
والتي انطلقت بعد تصاعد انتفاضة
من يولد ليحمل الراية في الارض
العربية فلسطين.
عشرون عاما على خير نموذج
للانتصار على الاحتلال. في